j'espère que tu as conscience que la
distance que tu essayes de mettre entre
nous ne diminue en rien l'affection que
je te porte tous les efforts que tu
feras pour me repousser sans voix à
l'échec
écoute je t'aime beaucoup j'adore qu'on
est tous les deux
et tout ça et je crois qu'il faut éviter
d'aller trop loin
ah bon pourquoi parce que je veux pas
que tu souffres mais je n'en voudrai pas
tu comprends pas ce que je te suis
contrainte est tout à fait clair cela
dit mais crois moi je tends voudrais pas
ça serait même un privilège d'avoir le
coeur brisé par toi pourquoi mais parce
que je suis une grenade un de ces jours
je vais exploser et absolument tout ce
qui m'entoure sera pulvérisé
j'essaie juste de faire un minimum de
victimes c'est quand même la moindre des
choses dedans